no I did I lost on time that's what
happened well that's the first time
you've ever lost then you never have
time management problems I mean that's
the truth that's not you you play so
fast man
I can't even keep up with you actually
blistering fast I know the speed is
unreal
I've learned bullet chess from you
actually so how have you felt since
since pogchamp see feel mentally
recovered ready to ready to get even
better yeah I actually feel even sharper
I took like three days off and then I
played four matches last night and I won
three out of four Wow today I'm two and
two right I don't think I've lost guys
you're almost back to 900 but yeah I
think the break is is very important
especially after like a big tournament
victory like that when your nerves are
shot sometimes like I've had some of my
best tournaments and I'd come home and
I'd play i binge online chess that got a
celebration and I'd play like some of my
absolute worst dresses like I couldn't
focus I was too jittery so I'm glad he
took the break and are ready to get
refocused again I'm absolutely ready man
yeah take me under your wing here let me
suck on that bottom where we where we
had and absolutely I think we're heading
I know you've gotten warmed up a little
bit but I need to reapply Matt sighs -
watching you know greatness in action so
why don't we start with one or two
warm-up games in the pool and you can
walk me through your newfound mastery of
the game that sounds like a plan yeah
that works for me and we'll go from
there I have some exercises prepared and
we're gonna take this thing to the next
level this is where things actually get
kind of fun
gasp well that's what I like to hear all
right so this one
four nights of defense yeah classics man
the classics can't escape them oh he's
already stumped in Norway apparently
where this guy's from they don't have
any good chests for his from other than
this idiot magnus carlsen is he from
Norway yes oh yeah nice and he I have a
funny story about him but okay so
actually thanks Julius for the sub he
has made already a mistake believe it or
not
oh yeah he blocked this Bishop before
develop that's the conceptual part of
the mistake you can actually punish him
tactically though is it by pinning the
Knight to King here ended so that's not
such a big deal look at remember let's
go back to first principles what is the
weakest pawn on the board do you mean
right now we're in general in general
when when you start the game what is the
weakest square on the chessboard a
square that's only defended by the King
and by nothing else right which is that
f7 on right now so put pressure on it uh
I mean I believe I could yeah so I can
bring my knight over there to g5 is this
one we want to do the g5 yes this is one
of the few times and this might seem
like childish or amateurish but he
cannot defend upon
he can't castle here normally the way to
defend against that would be to castle
but the latest castling and so he has to
his best move relatively speaking is to
play Bishop to e6 and he does give up a
pawn there because you have two
attackers on that Square and he's only
got one defender but at least he doesn't
lose f7 because if he loses f7 disaster
well he finds it ok ok so this is what I
would just want to throw bishop and fish
up here right sure you can take with
either piece twice it doesn't it's a
matter of taste yeah I feel more
comfortable with nights than bishops to
be honest well also because you take
with a knight and you attack the Queen
so you force further dis coordination
and among his ranks
what are you waiting for mmm so from I
take this pawn on e6 with my knight and
then I just drop him back when he
attacks take the bishop yeah where you
can drop it back to the same spot or you
can take the bishop either move is fine
whatever you sort of prefer if you
prefer slight simplification I would
take the bishop just because eliminate
this many pieces up upon that's that's
not a bad idea and continue development
as normal okay so even though it's only
one pawn up it's still worth you'd say
what excuse me your honor that it's not
a kind of I haven't served you a queen
on a golden platter ah ah split you have
to satisfy ourselves with mere pawns
okay just hey I'm just making sure no no
it and I know what you're saying like
sometimes you orchestrate all this all
this business for just like a measly
little pawn but the higher rank to
become like the the more important like
very very small gains in the position
become like pawns like to me if I had
this position against black with a
fellow Grandmaster like this this guy
turbo Fist it was known as as someone
who's very good at converting advantages
I would already basically be considering
close to considering resignation
especially after rook to it now he
deprives himself with castling rights on
top of him
I see say your quitter is what you're
telling me
mmm that's what you implied that's what
you choose to imply then you know from
here just no way absolutely not I got a
can't get away from that look at his
King like he should have castled long at
least now his King stranded in the
center yeah so he's looking to get in
here on c2 but that's not really much of
a bother right now right I can just
develop queen out here to protect that
or he's already protecting c2 yeah but
it's not developed do I just want to do
bishop anyway bishop yeah where do you
thinking where are you thinking of
developing that Bishop I was thinking
yeah for e3 yeah I could look towards
hanging clones good so you wanna and
also you can potentially remove that
night from the board as you kind of
mention and
and ruin his pawn structure see I like
that you're not automatically going to
g5 all the time yeah I've definitely
broken that habit I think the the fork
training is what was really helpful with
them mmm-hmm yeah so now the question is
do you take the knight or do you leave
it on d4 what what does your gut say in
a situation like this I would probably
take it get rid of it because it's it's
annoying you it's sitting on g4 it's
there's only strong piece and also
you're forcing him to get you know
doubled pawns which is not an ideal
thing to have he takes with this one
okay now you need to think immediately
about where you want to park this Knight
in the long run it's not about the next
move it's about where you want to
maneuver this Knight 2 moves into the
game and we've talked about this we've
talked about this particular maneuver
before actually yeah so it's not going
to d5 right now since the Knights still
on it even though that's attacking is
Queen or is that actually what you had
in mind way which move Knight to d5 I
like it I love it because and you can
play that move do you see what happens
after the night trade what additional
benefit do you derive from that trade
the only thing I see is it's opening up
a file you can go but rook e1 might win
as Queen oh yes of thinking Rd you're
thinking like three four steps ahead
what does a trade create that's not
something we used to do right now
doesn't have any drawbacks yes it does
you make a weak pun of your own on g5
but it's it's totally worth yeah this
isn't even something I even looked at I
guess I'm just so used to like knowing
the King's not there because people
Castle but yeah we'll meet you actually
this is an unusual position okay he
doesn't take your night okay mm-hmm that
means I can't pin that Queen after it
take with his knight this time around so
you want to go about it in the corner
for a little while no I'm a big boy okay
so what does mind here taking his night
with my knight just pushes his rook up
so I don't know what is your opinion on
that having the rook being up on the six
rank there
matter I would just do it for the sake
of simplicity it's one of those things I
told you where it really doesn't matter
where his rook is your king is very safe
anyway so it's not like he's gonna be
orchestrating a rook lift because it's I
would just remove the tension from the
board here because you are up upon and
after you take his knight then you can
work on activating your queen and
connecting your Oaks and then perhaps
even preparing an e5 pawn push to open
up the center that allows you to exploit
the weakness of his cane so what comes
to mind here well with all the port
training I was looking at immediately
seeing if I could win anything by
putting him in check on h5 see if I
could slide anything but since that
pawns defended on c5 that doesn't work
h7 that's true I could win the pawn on
h7 but what I was looking at if I did go
to e5 he takes with his paw and I put
him in check I wouldn't that pawn I put
him in check 1 Wow
ok yes I that is like the highest level
combination you found this far so you
want to play pawn to e5 20 bucks
goodness and then queen h5 picking off
that one opening up the e-file okay I
will give you my daily piece of praise
that was kind of sick ok now that's
something you would have balance a
little bit earlier oh but I'm pretty
sure this guy's in the chat there's no
one that would have seen me out game 6
is a very I love but it's still I mean
remember why you play d5 you played it
in order to open up the e-file so go
ahead and do that yeah can't believe
yeah these people like immediately he
doesn't take the pawn - it's not like
not about it okay what is his threat so
I know he's looking to get Queen over
there on h2 by attacking that pawn fast
oh yeah
so the natural way of defending that
right is just pushing up to g3 with the
pawn sure no blunting the Queen it's
better than playing h3 I would say
because now the Queen is just staring at
the stronghold on on g3 yeah I always
worry about playing h3 when it's being
attacked like that just because I'm
never quite sure you know like I don't
have an escape there anything and I
don't have a way of getting in it's just
not that's oh yeah you're right the
Queen on d6 still defense h2 so it
doesn't fully defend your back rank yeah
absolutely
yeah he's definitely not playing like an
800 plate neither are you so thanks
prefer Nidhi for the as this one guy
would say the fat if that's up I'm
saying that like I'm winning thank you
for the fat tango subs
really it's a nice thing are you gonna
sue me for plagiarism mmm
you're gonna are you gonna give me a
pass this one time yeah let it slide
about I don't have catchphrases you know
it's not a big deal
Jesus this guy's out for blood so where
is he going with his queen oh so he's
dropped to d7 he's now got the two
diagonals going over to a4 if he doesn't
really get too much out of that position
I have a hanging pawn at b2 if he brings
his Queen over to b5 the other way
though okay and then on the other
diagonal he can squeeze in two maybe
look for a rook or he's gonna bring the
Queen over to h3 and still do the same
plan so by bringing the Queen and h3
though he abandons his own King so you
need to urgently for a prayer urgently
prepare the manoeuvre of the a1 rook to
e1 but to do that what do you need to do
first I need to move my queen so when
it's closed active square for the Queen
e2 it's a quick check and then I bring
rook in okay but I would actually not
give that check as its sins the king
over to f8 where it wants to go anyway
cut the King off from as potential
escape via f8 to g8 so where can the
Queen go to cut the King off entirely
bringing the Queen over to f3 that's
what I would actually do Luke oh no it's
not a bad idea but Queen f3 is the most
accurate execution here because we're
tempting him into going Queen to h3
which leaves his King basically wide
open now he does threaten checkmate
but you basically come first like it's
your first you are the first one to
start punching him you know yeah
and yeah he's definitely finding some
some pretty high level ideas I have to
say I mean he's listening to you right
now of course he is well okay now he
does play Quidditch - so what do you do
so what came to mind for me was bringing
the rook in here on a one and well yeah
bringing rook into e1 that puts him in
check he can't block I mean yeah do it
do it do it do it
he can't block with his rook but okay so
now you have to look for ways to
continue attacking moves that occurred
to you the first move that came to mind
was pushing Queen to d5 which puts
another check on there the problem well
there is he escapes the CA can you do
that so that he doesn't escape with this
King to c8
by going over to b7 yep yeah that's the
best move okay
and the problem is your time situation
is a little Mont ass but you know
okay so king over fully assimilating in
dirt which cultural completely
completely so now it depends on whether
you think you're gonna make it see the
best move here is actually to just
defend against checkmate with Queen g2
and transition into an endgame two pawns
up but because you're so low on time I
would actually repeat moves and make a
draw here just because there's a long
time so which other check can you give
[Music]
just a seven better than he 70 you keep
allowing the King to walk over to like
c6 don't allow the King to to walk over
to the other side of the board it's
another it's a different kind of check
I'm a little confused the it's the only
other possible queen check other than
each seven literally the only other one
bringing it to eight strokes yes and
once you do that see the point is that
if you whistle seven you can take the
pawn at a seven you kind of box him in
now I would just repeat moves if I were
you
because you have no no time left yeah
he's definitely play that played a very
good game now you are technically
winning here after queen g2 but you're
also not who sit not be with same bolts
of chess so okay so do you see the
defense though do you see what I mean by
Queen g2 yeah so what you wanted me to
do there is when I take over on the pawn
so g7 I take very on Jesus
I put Queen over there like I'm seeing
Kettering the Queen yeah man we just
trade them yeah he can choose not to
trade Queens but his King is so wide
open then your King becomes say if we
trade Queens and you get an end game
where you have two pawns up which is
basically completely winning for white
but essentially before you jump into the
next game let me let me do the dreaded
thing I'm inviting you very quickly just
very quickly to an analysis board yeah
just a couple of things I wanted to get
because I know I was a little confusing
with some of the the guidelines for
checking okay just invited you
yeah so essentially blah blah blah so
first of all does this make sense he has
no other defense of this square yeah
now if I were actually playing white
intense let's say GM there is like a
five head move here that I didn't point
out to you where actually and maybe
you'll try you can try to find it it's
I'll give you this hint it's not moving
this night believe it or not hmm
you do not move this Knight and somehow
you indirectly defend it yeah I think I
see it immediately so you're just
pushing the other Knight to d5 so when
he's a queen exactly and he's got to
take unite in the second purpose of this
moment you take with a fun look at this
bone in his throat yeah he's got to
bring the knight back to d8
and now I want you to find another move
that normally I wouldn't ask you to find
again you don't want to make the
concession of moving this night away can
you support this night so that this
night is then replaced by upon any six
to find a defense of the night where I'm
going to end up with a pawn there yeah
so you want to keep that bone in his
throat basically is it bringing it to
Queen g4 it is that's exactly it and
look at this position it looks like a
measly pawn on e6 but it's like the
freaking sword of Damocles over his
position your plan here is just to
develop pieces d3 Bishop g5 this is kind
of cool is queen actually could get
literally trapped in the center of the
board
look at this thing okay okay that's how
effective a pawn can be in a square like
e6 um so that's what I would do but here
like once you've won upon don't spend
too long trying to think of alternate
would just keep developing your pieces
that's like the that's what you default
to normally II five is great and what I
meant when I said don't let his kingdom
so you wanted to give a check on e2
right but I first thought your mind you
have to ask yourself well where is this
King can go in a potentially go to
escape all the checks and in my mind I
see the square on g8 if the King ends up
on g8 it's relatively sheltered by the
pond so the move we need to although it
is a check it is sending the king to a
square that it wants to hide to anyway
does that sort of make sense yeah and I
think that's something I need to look
for it moves that cut off the case
exactly so if this is not a check so
you're automatically maybe it's a little
bit of a it occupies a lower standing in
your book and your social hierarchy of
chess moves this is like you know this
is not very high up but the reality is
you've cut the King off from this file
now you send the King here and what I
meant here is
he's threatening checkmate so this move
does an action in a rook this doesn't
want a rope because he moves to c6 and
it's the same principle you haven't cut
the King off so it can run even to b5
you don't have any more checks here so
well you actually do and as a defensive
exercise for you how do you actually
defend against checkmate here because it
seems like you're out of checks except
you aren't but I'd like you to exercise
that sort of imaginative thinking
White's a play and not get checkmated
and don't you tell me Queen f6 check
staving off checkmate
no I know there's more that's brain is
thinking hey is it wrote to e6 he takes
with the rook I take with the rook it's
check again so it's 2 checks then it
forces him off wait so you want to go
here that's what I was thinking and then
Queen takes which is another check now
actually what's amazing about this is
you can take the other rook I didn't
even see this idea and you've distracted
the rook room from making contact with
h2 but there are problems I just go
right back to h6 and you're stuck with
the same problem so not quite there
actually is a check here that's a little
bit hard to see it's a little bit of a
weird geometry and your goal is again
Safian kettle the Queen in the end right
so I'm looking for a light tile and then
way to get Queen into g2 so it's just
bringing the Queen down to e4 dingo we
need for check queen g2 and you're safe
and sound and happy here so the only
reason you didn't do that is again
because of the time situation so other
than that I mean this movie 5 represents
serious growth because you not only
noticed a fork you orchestrated a fork
you actually set it up in order to gain
an open file and all of these concepts
are something that we've only recently
started a point so I'm very happy you
found this move thanks man yeah I really
think those puzzles really came and came
in big handy to see something like that
mm-hmm
that's not that's awesome well let's
jump in for one more if your Majesty
desires yeah Alex
the famous Brazilian warrior mmm one of
the best in the business from what I've
heard he's the Steph Curry of Brazil of
chess you probably I know who chef curry
is I'm just not a sports guy I don't
know I bring in sports references well
you know some of us basketball this is a
question I had for you so he's obviously
just mirroring the same thing do I want
to Castle now or just develop Bishop
what's better a valid Bishop usually he
because if he goes Knight g4 then you
can castle actually ohh oh my god way do
you remember oh [ __ ] this can be cool
you have a trick here that we went over
it's related to legals mate it occurs on
the same square and it exploits the fact
that the knight on g4 is undefended it's
just a vaguely remember going over it
but I it starts with a sacrifice a
temporary sacrifice yeah is it throwing
the night on the pawn at E 5 he takes
with Knight no you're going slightly
wrong direction it's not it doesn't have
anything to do with the pawn on e5 what
it has to do with is the fact that the
knight on g4 is unprotected so you can
see the Queen making x-ray contact with
the knight on g4 so if you're thinking
about this logically you have to set up
a situation where you move the knight
from f3 with a gain of tempo which in
our neck of the woods essentially means
with check that should give you enough
information to basically orchestrate
this combination I'm moving the knight
right now for a check you first you have
to bring the King out onto a square
where it can be checked by then the
Greek gift oh right yeah this is when
we're f7 the exact thing that's why he
made a mistake here if this pawn was
already on d6 then his Bishop would be
guarding that night so this wouldn't
work but this is something you have to
remember it's a very common idea I
totally forgot this was a game I thought
we were on the analysis Baha you're the
analysis board is in your nightmares
what have I done to you it's helpful so
when would sew that right there that's
something that's always gonna happen
when they try and push up for that
attack down there isn't it yeah so they
again tunnel vision they look at that
pot enough to their tongue flies out oh
my god I don't have to I can see it's
like you know the mousing cheese but
undefended theses are far from being the
center of their mind yeah did you pre
move that move no I actually just
dropped okay good because I was gonna
say if he took your night with his queen
this would not be a very smart move to
pre move yeah and then I would have just
taken Queen with Bishop so it would've
been a real dumb move from him too
exactly but people can be dirty like
that like auntie pre move dress I do
that sometimes where you like expect
your opponent Supreme of something it's
a trick in bullet chess and then you
basically okay so again this guy is
playing reasonably he found a good move
here yeah so again threatening that pawn
down there at c2 so the natural way of
defending that is just bringing Queen
all the way back d1 right absolutely
I'll show you some five head solutions
for this after the game but for the all
intents and purposes here Queen d1 is
very solid and then you got to start
immediately working on asking yourself
can I get rid of this knight on d4 okay
whoa whoa whoa that was a very serious
mistake you asleep because again in your
mind he's not castled and he's rocking
around by pushing his funds instead of
castling maybe okay um well I can't hmm
I'm sure I'm trying to think of like
think so the first move that came to my
head is one that I don't think pans out
the first move that I thought of was
going Knight d5 and then looking to get
an attack in that direction but I don't
think that punishes that move he just
made right there nope it does not now
the mover that he made right there
remember first principles you have to
start by looking at checks checks and
captures are the first anchor in any
position like this
mm-hmm so go through that process don't
try to kind of shortcut it and if you do
that what moves do you come up with well
the next thing was Queen check on h5 I
mean he can't take that fork down there
at c2 since he'll be in check there then
I'd look for the checkmate on exactly
and why is age six a mistake because
normally after Queen hy that move can be
met with g6 blocking the check but here
the pawn on g6 has lost its support
exactly now it's not gonna be direct
checkmate if he brings this King up to
e7 but what you do have is a combination
to win his Queen in two moves which I
would like you to then fun something you
would not have I would not have expected
you to find even like let's say a week
ago but now I think you have the tools
necessary to to crack it open assuming
he's pushing King to ease of him yeah
which he just did White's move in with
the Queen and two moves and you need to
ask yourself immediately well how
theoretically am I even gonna win the
Queen like what tactical techniques am I
gonna use this one actually is your
favorite yeah so this is going right up
there to d5 which puts a check oh yeah
you saw it immediately - he's got to go
up to d6 and then you pick off the Queen
how with a fork exactly and I did until
to injury you even take the Queen with
check so he can't even take the pawn on
c2 and the rook on a1 for some sort of
consolation he's just gonna live with it
and yeah I think he was sirheo Alice I
think this might be his only Lawson is
and his long and illustrious chess
career charlie yeah that's what I was
and he just resigned it's very nice mmm
so this Bishop f7 is a brutal
combination so before you jump in I want
to show you like again I I want to be
careful about doing this and I don't
want to overwhelm you with [ __ ] but I
just want to give you a flavor of like
how chess works at like a really high
level yeah I think that helps and I
think you'll understand this I think
this is a logic that that's relatively
easy to grasp
okay I'm gonna so close that previous
analysis port and all about you to a new
one I'm ready
okay okay so essentially to akes 95
check okay couple things first of all if
he would have sacrificed his Queen it's
not as as as simple as innocuous as it
appears he can take on f2 here and he
Forks your queen in his rook and in your
book could you give me at least two ways
to deal with this move without losing
the rook on h1 one way is something you
should see quite quickly the other is
like a really beautiful move that you're
gonna kind of like Wow so I'm looking
for a move that doesn't lose that rook
right so move like Queen d2 loses the
rockin black gets a lot of little little
you know trinkets for for the Queen
against a rook and a piece can you avoid
black winning this rook just by moving
the rook but that sax the Queen okay
well you're actually quite close if you
move the rook look at a blacks King
whenever the King is bowling right where
can you go just right up there to f1 UK
exactly bingo [ __ ] and pinning and
actually you can even do something
crazier you can actually just castle in
this position you actually that actually
is illegal some people listen wait a
minute that's an illegal move so even
though you push rook to f1 you can still
castle off that yeah yeah no but your
where are you asking exactly well I'm
sure okay I thought you canceled after
you moved rook I was gonna say what the
[ __ ] kind of crazy
no you Castle here in the face of this
night and I want the other book though
I'm not satisfied just by that I want
the other way of stopping you from
losing the rook I need to empty my
bladder so I will give you 30 seconds to
come up with this I'll be right back
okay
yes I'm back then it's the queen to
freeze up check and then you can move
the rook mm-hmm a real reason to play
that over the castling right I would
play the gasoline because also the
castling
you can basically primo rook takes f2
afterward and then you get on top of
everything else two rooks for a piece so
you basically are just gonna have an
extra queen after that yeah or two
pieces for a rope round there misspoke
I'm good
other than this this is the moment that
I wanted to kind of inspire you in okay
after you played 94 remember I mentioned
how the better you get the less reactive
you become like the better you get the
less afraid you are of threats because
you begin to realize that in chess
there's only a certain number of threats
that truly need to be reacted to like if
your opponent to play d6 attacking your
queen yes this is a situation where I
would have to move the Queen but if he
plays 94 I'm looking at this pawn and
I'm kind of scoffing at it because I'm
looking at his King and how weak it is
and my first thought is not how do I
defend this pawn and and bringing the
Queen back to defend this pawn is can I
ignore this threat and take the sting
out of it so that I can actually focus
on attacking so the move that I would
make here is actually just a castle and
basically you know be like take this fun
be my guest
take this one I don't care okay and now
I'm like can I sacrifice this roar can I
keep accumulating pieces on the King
side to sacrifice this rook and I think
the answer is yes I would play the move
Knight e5 accumulating bringing another
piece into the attacking after takes I
think there is a very very simple move
Queen at five after which even to you it
should become very very clear that
White's threats here are unstoppable
what is specifically his wife
threatening right going right to f7
bingo Queen cannot move anyway that's
why we put the knight on d5 to stop the
Queen from coming to thee 7 remember
what I said the Queen and the knight are
the strongest like pair in all of chess
yeah well the Queen and the two knights
like Queen cooperating with two Knights
is
absolutely unstoppable so blacks only
defenses are up to f/8 now you stopped
off this pawn on e5 but you don't do it
just to take a pawn could you now find a
way to transform the advantage from an
attack to a very big material advantage
winning the Queen actually without
giving up my queen obviously so it's not
just taking that [ __ ] up with the night
right no no you don't wanna see you want
to win his queen because remember you
have sacrificed a rook here so you
better find a way to deliver something
yeah so what I looked at was pushing the
night Jesus I don't know why I started
on that 2h7 taking that pawn to threaten
that rook it's okay to be nervous so
that's actually a very sensible move but
you have a way to win the Queen directly
right away
yes look at his king desist king of any
squares no oh I see my checkmate yeah so
he's gonna be forced to take on c7
that's winning the Queen his knight on
a1 is also stranded he's also under a
huge attack so black and resigned in
this position basically right okay so
this is like the next level of tactics
when you are attacking it's like you're
on the freeway you're looking for the
exit you're always looking for a way to
exit the attack and basically what I
mean by that is you're always looking
for a way to transform the attack into a
very significant material advantage if
you don't see checkmate so a lot of
people think that and it's acting only
into checkmate like attacked the next
logical chain and the sequence is
checkmate but that's not true in fact
most attacks at a grand master level do
not actually end and check me some do
but a lot of them ends with a
transformation of the attack into let's
say an extra two bonds or an extra piece
or an extra queen something like that
does that kind of strike you as as
reasonable yeah that makes sense
yeah good so here's my proposed plan we
play one more game and then you
basically jump into the tactics pool and
I'm gonna follow you and we're not going
to do only fork related tactics I want
to see you do general tactics and I want
to kind of see you walk through it
because that's really the next step I
want you to get extremely fluent with
simple tactics I want you to be able to
see them in the snap of a face
that might not be the most interesting
thing but I think it's an absolute
absolute must